اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
بعد غارات قتلت 13 شخصا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يجلي مستوطنات محيطه بغزه ويتوقع الرد على
اكثر من جبهه
[تصفيق]
روسيا تحتفل بيوم النصر عبر التاكيد على
مواصله الحرب ودعوات اوروبيه لمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا
اعداد النازحين السودانيين تتضاعف في غضون
اسبوع ومنظمه الهجره تعلن عن تجاوز عددهم
700 الف في الداخل فقط
اعمال شغب واشتباكات في كراتشي في باكستان
بعد اعتقال عمران خان والشرطه تعلن حال
الاستعداد القصوى
اهلا بكم يتصاعدوا التوتر في قطاع غزه بعد
غارات اسرائيليه ادت الى مقتل 13 شخصا
بينهم نساء واطفال فضلا عن عشرين جريحا
بينهم حالات حرجه بحسب ما اعلنت وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن عن شن
عمليه عسكريه في غزه الاستهداف مواقع
وقاده بارزين من حركه الجهات
الجيش الاسرائيلي عمد الى اجلاء الاف
المستوطنين من محيط غزه واكد استعداده لكل
سيناريوهات بما فيها معركه طويله الامد
كما عمد الى نشر بطاريات للقبه الحديديه
على الحدود مع سوريا وسط معلومات ان
اسرائيل تتوقع الرد على عمليه غزه من اكثر
من جبهه في الشمال والجنوب
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول عقب الضربات الجويه
ومقتل فلسطينيين انها عمليه عسكريه في
استهداف مواقع وقاده بارزين من حركه
الجهاد اطلق عليها اسم السهم الواقي
مسؤولون فلسطينيون اكدوا مقتل ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد في الغارات ومدنيين بينهم
اطفال الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان ان
قواته شنت هجمات مركزه على القطاع طالت
عشره مواقع لانتاج اسلحه ومجمعات عسكريه
لحركه الجهاد وفق بيان الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وان العمليه التي خطط لها الثلاثاء الماضي
شاركت فيها اربعون طائره وقال ان ثلاثه من
قاده الجهاد وهم قائد منطقه شمال قطاع غزه
في حركه الجهاد وقيادي بارز في الحركه
المسؤول عن توجيه نشاطات في الضفه الغربيه
انطلاقا من غزه وايضا امين سر المجلس
العسكري هذا وفق البيان الاسرائيلي
حركه الجهاد قالت ان ثلاثه من ابرز قادتها
في القطاع هم خليل البهتيني وطارق عز
الدين وجهاد غنام قتلوا خلال الضربات
الاسرائيليه
متوعده بالرد وتكبيد اسرائيل ثمنا كبيرا
لعمليتها في غزه كما شددت على عدم مغادره
مواقعها في القطاع اما وزاره الصحه في غزه
فاعلنت انه اضافه الى مقتل واصابه العشرات
تعمل طواقم الاسعاف على اجلاء الضحايا من
المناطق التي تم قصفها
ومع استمرار التصعيد في غزه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه موافقه وزيرها على
استدعاء قوات الاحتياط حسب متطلبات الجيش
والحاجه لمشاركتهم في مواجهات محتمله جاسم
محسن العربيه
مسؤول استخباراتي اسرائيلي اكد للقناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان عمليه غزه
استهدفت حركه الجهاد وليس حركه حماس مضيفا
انهم مستعدون لكل السيناريوهات اذا قررت
حماس الانضمام لرد حركه الجهاد
وجاء هذا عقب انتهاء جلسه المشاورات
الامنيه بين رئيس الوزراء بني مينا
نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع
ومسؤوليه الاستخبارات لتقييم الوضع
الميداني
وفي اتصال مع الوسطاء اخبرت اسرائيل كلا
من مصر وقوات اليونيف العامله في جنوب
لبنان بانها سترد بشكل راضع على اي هجمات
عسكريه تنطلق من قطاع غزه او من جنوب
لبنان وفق ما نقلت القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه
واضافت القناه ان تل ابيب هددت في
الاتصالات التي اجرتها مع الوسطاء هددت
حركه حماس في قطاع غزه وحزب الله في لبنان
برد رادع فيما لو قراراه الرد على هجماتها
فجر اليوم على القطاع
معي مباشره من حدود قطاع غزه مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلب زياد اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني زياد هل
نتوقع ردا كبيرا الليله من قبل الفصائل في
غزه وماذا عن الجبهه الشماليه هل ستظل
هادئه ام لا كل التوقعات تشي بانها ستفتح
قريبا
كل السيناريوهات قد تكون ممكنه ولكن
التوقعات الرئيسيه هي بالفعل بان تقوم
الجهاد الاسلامي وربما باقي الفصائل ايضا
بالمشاركه في عمليه رد صاروخيه واسعه
النطاق على اسرائيل قد لا تقتصر بالضروره
على ما يسمى منطقه غلاف قطاع غزه اي من
صفر الى اربعين كيلومترا المنطقه الجنوبيه
وقد تمتد الى وسط اسرائيل رح تل ابيب
ومطار تل ابيب لهذا راينا اسرائيل منذ
ساعات الصباح عمليا قامت بنشر بطاريات قبه
حديديه في محيط المطار ووسط اسرائيل
بالاضافه الى نشر بطاريات قبه حديديه ايضا
على جبهه لبنان وسوريا خشيه من ربما
محاولات اطلاق صواريخ ولو بشكل رمزي
للتضامن مع ما يحدث مع قطاع غزه بنيامين
نتنياهو انها قبل بعض الوقت اجتماعا جديدا
امنيا مع وزير الدفاع ومستشار الامن
القومي وقاده الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه هذا الجسم هو الذي يتخذ
القرارات العملاتيه بعد دقائق ايضا تم
تفكير موعد الحكومه الامنيه المصغره في
ختامها من المتوقع ان يدلي نتنياهو
بالتصريح مقتضب هو وزير الدفاع ايضا حول
مجريات الامور حاليا هناك حال من الانتظار
وهناك استغراب نوعا ما في اسرائيل
لانتظار حماس عفوا الجهاد والفصائل عمليا
وقتا كبيرا نسبيا للرد حتى الساعه طيب
زياد يظل السؤال المركزي والكبير الان هل
ستدخل حماس هذه المعركه وهذه المواجهه ما
هي التوقعات خصوصا وان اسرائيل حاولت يعني
استثناء حماس وقالت ان المواجهه مقتصره
على حركه الجهاد ولكن التوقعات بان حماس
ستدخل هذه المعركه وفق متابعتك ام لا يعني
الامور غير واضحه
الامور غير واضحه ولكن ليس مستبعدا ابدا
اساسا بسبب ربما ضغط القاعده الشعبيه
راينا الجنازات المهيبه التي كانت في قطاع
غزه مشاركه اعداد هائله من الناس في هذه
الجنازات ليس فقط للقاده من الجهاد
الاسلامي وانما اساسا للاطفال الذين عمليا
قتلتهم اسرائيل هذا قد يضطر حماسي
للمشاركه ولو جزئيا في عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ على اسرائيل هذا وفق بعض
التقديرات حتى داخل
المؤسسه الامنيه في اسرائيل
عمليا وبالتالي هذا متغير قد يكون مهما
جدا في طبيعه المجواجه وان كانت التقديرات
حتى الساعه ما تزال تتحدث ربما عن مواجهه
قد تكون فيها قوه ناريه كبيره نسبيا ولكن
قد تكون قصيره الابد نسبيا ايضا هذه
الليله وفق التوقعات زياده ستكون حبلى
بكثير من المفاجات ولكن يعني في سؤال
مطروح كانت الامور هادئه نسبيا زياد ما
عدا مما بدا لتقوم حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
بهذه الاستهدافات وهل ما جرى يخدم نتنياهو
داخليا يعني هنا لب المساله
صحيح
القرار اتخذ طالب يوم الجمعه الماضي ولم
يتخذ في الحكومه الامنيه المصغره كما كان
يجب ان يكون متوقعا على الاقل وانما في
جسم مصغر اكثر مطبخ امني مصغر اكثر
نتنياهو وزير الدفاع مستشار الامن القومي
وقاده الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه اجتمعوا
الجمعه الماضي في مقر الشباك الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله واتخذ القرار
باستهداف القاده الثلاثه قاده الجهاد
الاسلامي في قطاع غزه
والانتظار ساعه التنفيذ التي تكون منوطه
بالمعلومات الاستخباراتيه الدقيقه وهو ما
حصل فجر هذا اليوم طبعا امنيا تحاول
اسرائيل ان تفسر وتقول بان ذلك ياتي
لترميم قدره الرضع كما تسمى في مواجهه
قطاع غزه بعد ان ازداد الحديث امنيا في
اسرائيل عن فقدان قدره الردع ان كان على
جبه غزه هنا جنوبا او على جبهه لبنان
وسوريه شمالا لكن بدون ان شك لا فكاك من
المعادله الداخليه في اسرائيل كان من قال
في اسرائيل بان نتنياهو يبحث عن تهدئه
داخل اسرائيل وليس مع الفصائل في قطاع غزه
بمعنى تهدئه تحول دون الانتقادات التي
توجه للحكومه دون الاحتجاجات التي تقوم ضد
الحكومه يوميا وفي محاوله ربما لوقف
الانهيار في شعبيته شخصيا وفي شعبيه احزاب
اليمين ككل داخل القاعده اليمنيه في
اسرائيل
تصعيد كهذا قد يفيد نتنياهو كثيرا لجهه
ربما ترميم هيئه هذه الحكومه بالقول انها
مبادره وتقوم بعمليات ليس فقط ردا على
اطلاق صواريخ وانما تبادر الى الاغتيالات
لكن تمت من يتساءل في اسرائيل ان كانت
سياسه الاغتلاء اغتيالات ناجحه
وتعود على اسرائيل بالردع اذا لماذا تتكرر
كل تسعه اشهر
من حدود قطاع غزه مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين زياد حلبي دائما شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد كشفت مصادر مطلعه للعربيه بان
القاهره وفي محاوله منها لمنع تصعيد
الاوضاع في القطاع كانت قد حذرت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه منذ اسبوع من عمليات
اغتيال اسرائيليه تستهدف قاده فيها واضافت
المصادر للعربيه ان القاهره تقوم باتصالات
موسعه حاليا لمنع التصعيد وذلك عبر اجراء
اتصالات مباشره مع اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه بهدف في تمديد التهدئه
من جهتها ابلغت الفصائل الفلسطينيه الوسطى
انها سترد على عمليات الاغتيال منهيه
التهدئه التي تم الاتفاق عليها قبل ايام
فيما ابلغت اسرائيل الوسطاء بانتهاء
عمليتها العسكريه بشكل مؤقت عقب الهجمات
العسكريه ضد اهداف لحركه الجهاد فجر اليوم
الى قطاع غزه ينضم الي من هناك الصحفي
محمد عوض الاستاذ محمد اهلا وسهلا بك الى
هذه النشره من العربيه هل تتحضر غزه لحرب
طويله المدى املا مجرد رد مضاد وتنتهي
الامور كما جرت العاده ام لا الامور
مختلفه هذه
بالفعل طالب يعني غزه بكل مكوناتها
تستعد لجوله تصعيد قد تمتد لايام وعلى غير
العاده وعلى غير المعلوم الشارع هنا في
قطاع غزه يتساءل لماذا حتى هذه اللحظه
الفصائل لم تطلق الصواريخ ولم
على اغتيال شهداء الجهاد الاسلامي لكن
بالمحصله الفصاله الفلسطينيه تستخدم تكتيك
جديد وهو استراتيجيه جديده يبدو هذه
الاستراتيجيه
تمثل
بعمليه استنزاف القوى واشغال الطرف الاخر
وهذا الامر يرهق اسرائيل مرارا وتكرارا
حاولت غزه اشغال الغلاف قطاع غزه واشغال
الحدود
وتهجير المستوطنين
واخلاقهم لكن سرعان ما ينتهي كل هذه
الاجراءات بعد قيام اسرائيل بعمليه اغتيال
او ضربه استباقيه كما نستطيع القول لكن
على الصعيد
الاجتماعي والشعب هنا في غزه الجميع ينتظر
ما ستقول اليه
قطاع غزه يعني
وانا هناك
قطاعي غزه لان الاحتلال او عفوا نعم في
جنوب قطاع غزه الحديث الاول عن استهداف من
قبل
يبدو المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
يا استاذ محمد يعني الاخبار العاجله ترد
انه في قصف اسرائيلي شرق خان يونس
بجنوب قطاع غزه لكن قصف مدفعي يعني قصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي حسب ما يؤكد مراسل العربيه
شرق خان يونس تفضل
الانباء الاوليه تفيد بان مدفعيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتمركزه تحديدا شرق خان يونس
جنوب قطاعي غزه استهدفت هدفا ما لكن لا
نستطيع تحديد ما هو هذا الهدف بسبب يعني
بعد المكان الذي يتم الاستهداف بداخله ثم
ان هذا الخبر يبقى اول وهو بشكل عاجل
وردنا الان من الزملاء في المنطقه بان
هناك استهداف من قبل
نعم
والانباء تتضارب الان يبدو الان الميدان
بدا يتحرك وبدات
ولكن القصف هو قصف اسرائيلي يعني الفصائل
حتى الساعه لم لم ترد محمد
حتى الان الفصائل تلتزم الصمت عدا عن بيان
لي الغرفه
المشتركه التابعه لفصائل
الفصائل المسلحه
وقالت في على اسرائيل ان تستعد بما هو
قادم وهو تهديد واضح وفي تكتيك جديد بان
الفصائل في قطاع غزه لن تمرر هذه الضربه
ولن تمرر هذا التصعيد وهي مقبله على رد
لكن كيف يكون شكل الرد وحجم الرد هذا كله
مرهون بالساعات او ربما الدقائق القادمه
الجميع هنا يركب في غزه بس السؤال المركزي
السؤال المركزي اللي سالته حتى لزياد يعني
في غموض بعد في الموقف السؤال المركزي هل
ستدخل حركه حماس
بالدرجه الاولى وباقي الفصائل هذه
المواجهه الان ام لا ستكون حركه الجهاد هي
المعنيه مباشره فقط
زميلي طالب ما حدث اليوم هو يؤكد بان حماس
من تدير هذا التصعيد رغم
ان من الجهاد الاسلامي لكن حماس تدير
التصعيد هي من انشات غرفه العمليات
المشتركه التابعه للفصائل الفلسطينيه
وجمعت كل الفصائل
ووضعتهم تحت جناحها كما صح التعبير بان
القرار يكون مشترك الرد يكون مشترك
والمواجهه تكون مشتركه وبالتالي خروج
الغرفه المشتركه بهذا البيان هذا يعني ان
الغرفه المشتركه تحدثت بالبيان باسم حماس
والجهاد واثني عشر فصيلا عسكريا مسلحا
يعمل على الارض ونحن تابعنا هذا البيان
بدقه وجدنا بانه يحمل
التهديد المفتوح بمعنى لم تقل كما كانت
المرات السابقه ان
ريفه مع غزه هذه الليله او
ننتظر
ونرى من قطاع غزه الصحفي محمد عوض شكرا
جزيلا لك محمد على هذه المشاركه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
بيكين تهدد بالرد على الاتحاد الاوروبي
انفرض عقوبات على شركاتها لتعاملها مع
روسيا
اهلا بكم من جديد تدخل الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه يوما جديدا من التصعيد الشرس
فيما تحاول القوات الروسيه تحقيق اكبر
مكاسب لها على الارض بعد سعي الجيش
الاوكراني الحثيث لاستعاده اراضيه وقالت
الاداره العسكريه في كييف انظمه الدفاع
الجوي تتصدى لهجمات الروسيه على المدينه
بعد اطلاق انذارات جويه في عموم مدن
البلاد وتحديدا على مشارف كييف بينما اكد
رئيس بلديه كييف العثور على حطام بمنطقه
شفشنسكي التي يكثر استهدافها بالاضافه الى
سقوط حطام على منزل جنوب العاصمه لم يسفر
عن وقوع ضحايا اما اعلن قائد قوات ان
قواته سيطرت على 180 مترا في عمق المحور
الغربي بالتزامن مع وصول اول امدادات
الاسلحه والذخيره واضاف قائد قوات الجيش
الاوكراني يسيطر حاليا على نحو كيلومترين
فقط في نفس المحور
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الوحدات الهجوميه
تواصل عملياتها في غرب بخمت وذلك بعد
تصريحات لقائد خلالها ان وحدات روسيا سحبت
من مواقعها هناك واشار المتحدث باسم
الوزاره
الى ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه قامت
بتوجيه ضربات باسلحه عاليه الدقه
الاحتياطات الجيش الاوكراني ومستودعات
الاسلحه والذخيره في هجمات خلال الليل
وحول الخلافات الاخيره بين قائد مجموعه
فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه كشفت تقرير
لصحيفه لوفيجارو الفرنسيه انه يمكن ان
تكون حادثه تهديد قائد مجموعه فاجنر
بالانسحاب من باخمد مجرده ظاهره ثانويه في
قلب الخلافات الروسيه
ولفت التقرير الى ان تصريحات بريكوجين حول
الذخيره هي مجرد ذريعه لفك الارتباط من
صراع لم يعد يخدمه كونه رجل اعمال بالدرجه
الاولى وان مجموعته لا تقاتل في اوكرانيا
من اجل الوطن ولكن لصالح سيدها
وبحسب التقرير فان اوكرانيا ليست القضيه
الرئيسيه لفاغنر وبريغوجين اذ تمتدوا
شبكته بشكل اساسي الى افريقيا حيث ينمو
نفوذه ولا ينبغي ان يتسبب فشلهم او ان
يتسبب فشلهم في اوكرانيا في خسارته
لعملائه كما اضاف التقرير ان الهزيمه
العسكريه لرجال بريكوجين في اوكرانيا
ستغير فرصه وطموحاته السياسيه داخل روسيا
وخلصت تقرير الى انه يمكن لزعيم فاقنرال
الخروج منتصرا من هذه المواجهه مع موسكو
من خلال المحافظه على علاقته بالرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين
طلبنا في ليله الثامن من مايو ذخيره
واسلحه لكن لم نتسلم سوى عشره في المئه من
المطلوب ومن الواضح الاصرار على مراجعه
طلباتنا وتقليصها ما يزال الوضع على اطراف
ضخمه متوترا بينما تركت وحدات من وزاره
الدفاع المواقعها التي حاربت قوه فاغنر من
اجل السيطره عليها بالدماء ولفتره طويله
بينما يكدس الاوكرانيون اسلحتهم ويحشدون
قواتهم الاحتياطيه لو وصلت الذخيره كما
نريد لكن الان نتقدم وكنا منذ فتره طويله
في سلوفيانسك واكراماتورسك
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اكد ان
بلاده تواجه اليوم حربا جديده تهدف الى
اسقاط روسيا وتدميرها وتفكيكها واشار ايضا
الى ان الوضع الذي تمر به اوكرانيا اليوم
مسؤول عنه الغرب الذي يصدر التوترات الى
حدود روسيا
اليوم حضارتنا مره اخرى تشهد نقطه تحول
حاسمه وتندلع حرب حقيقيه مره اخرى ضد
وطننا لكننا قاومنا الارهاب الدولي سنقوم
ايضا بحمايه سكان دومباس وضمان امننا
بالنسبه لروسيا لا توجد دول معاديه سواء
في الغرب او في الشرق كما هو الحال مع
الغالبيه المطلقه من الناس على هذا الكوكب
نريد ان نرى المستقبل سليما وحرا ومستقرا
اما المستشار الالماني فدعى اعضاء
البرلمان الاوروبي الى عدم الخوف من مظاهر
القوه التي يستعرضها الرئيس الروسي بلادي
اثناء احتفالات بلاده بيوم النصر على
المانيا النازيه واضاف شورت انه يجب
الاستمرار في الوقوف مع اوكرانيا
جنوده دباباته وصواريخه اليوم يجب ان لا
نخاف من استعراض القوه هذا دعونا نظل
ثابتين في دعمنا لاوكرانيا مهما طال الامر
على اي حال لا احد منا يريد العوده الى
الوقت الذي كان فيه منطق القوه سائدا في
اوروبا
الى كيف مجددا ينضم اليه لمزيد من
المتابعه مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني واخر
اخبار القصف الجوي الروسي حذيفه
طالب في الحقيقه يعني منذ ليله الامس وحتى
صباح اليوم قامت قوات الاتحاد الروسي بقصف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بثلاثين صاروخا اسقط
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه معظم هذه
الصواريخ كذلك كان هنالك 61 غاره جويه
نفذها جيش الاتحاد الروسي في عدد من
المناطق ودسه نيكلايف وكذلك
مخمودا كل واخر كيف كل هذه المناطق تعرضت
لعمليات قصف
لقارات جويه وكذلك 89 ضربه براجمات
الصواريخ تعرضت لها خط النار في جميع هذه
المناطق والمدن القريبه من خط النار طبعا
الوضع في باخمه كما هو عليه القوات
الاوكرانيه تصير على الدفاع عن هذه الجبهه
وان تمسك بها وذلك لكي تمسك بالقوات
الروسيه التي اذا ما استولت كما تقول على
مدينه بخموت سوف تجعل من الجبهه جبهه
عريضه جدا وستنتشر في جبهات اخرى وستفتح
عليها نيران هي الان تمسكها ببقائها
والسيطره على جبهه كما انها سوف تسيطر
طبعا على مدينه
وقبل قليل تفضلت وتحدثت عن الذي تحدثت عنه
ان القوات الروسيه اذا ما استطاعت ان
تسيطر على مخمود لذهبت الى
وهذه وهذا ما تبقى في اقليم
دونيسك تحديدا في ولايه دونيسك طبعا اليوم
عيد النصر طالب كما تعلم في الاتحاد
الروسي وهذا اللعيد هو عيد سوفيتي وكل
الدول الاتحاد السوفيتي ما زالت تحتفل
سابقا طبعا ما زالت تحتفل بهذا اليوم الا
كيف التي الغت هذا الاحتفال لم نشهد اي
مظاهر للاحتفال اليوم الاحتفال الرسمي من
الدوله تم الغائه كذلك تعلم انه يعني كان
هنالك عرض عسكريه يقوم ايضا كل ذلك تم
الغاءه قليل ولكن حذيفه
عرضا روسيا مهيبا في هذه الذكرى وكلمه
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين كيف كان وقع
هذا الاحتفال والمواقف التي اطلقها الرئيس
بوتين في هذه المناسبه في كييف
طبعا على الصعيد الرسمي علق ميخائيل
بودلاك على كلمه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في
هذا الاحتفال وقال ان هذا عالم من نسجد
خيال بوتين وان بوتين ينسج هذه القصص
لشعبه ولي العالم وينسجها ويصدقها ويقول
اننا مستهدفون واننا محاربون ولا احد لم
يحاربه في الحقيقه بوتين هو الذي يشن هذه
الحرب ضد الجميع وهو الذي دخل الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولم يكن اي عدوان قد حدث في
اتجاه الاتحاد الروسي من قبل اوكرانيا او
من قبل دول اخرى وايضا قال انه يدمر
امبراطور الامبراطوريه الروسيه وما يحلم
به في اعاده الاتحاد السوفيتي كل ذلك
يدمره بوتين بنفسه وبسلوكه وايضا تحدث عن
ان الشعب الروسي يعني يعيش في بروباندا
ودعايه كبيره جدا ينسجها روسي واعوانه هذا
كان تعليق ميخائي مستشار الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلينسكي على الصعيد الشعبي يعني بشكل
كبير ما نلاحظه انه لا احد يلقي بال ابدا
لهذه الاحتفالات وكان في او كرانيا او حتى
في الاتحاد الروسي الا طبعا اسر هنالك من
فقدوا زويهم في هذه الحرب هنالك من قاتلوا
في هذه الحرب وما زالوا احياء هم الذين
يحتفلون ويذهبون الى النصب التسكاري
فمراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك
حذيفه على كل هذه المتابعه
حذرت الصين الاتحاد الاوروبي من تبعات فرض
عقوبات على الشركات الصينيه بسبب تعاملها
مع روسيا وكان وزير الخارجيه الصيني خلال
لقائه مع نظيرته الالمانيه في برلين على
اتخاذ بلاده الخطوات اللازمه لحمايه
الاهداف المشروعه للشركات الصينيه مضيفا
انه من حق الشركات الصينيه والروسيه
التعاون فلا يجب ان تؤثر السياسه على ذلك
وذكر وزير الخارجيه الصيني نظيرته بان
بلاده لا توفر جهدا لحل الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بالعطر السلميه وتتعاون لذلك
كالغرض مع الجميع
كشف المتحدث باسم المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
ان اكثر من 700 الف نازح سوداني نزح
داخليا بسبب القتال الذي بدا في الخامس
عشر من ابريل مؤكدا ان الرقم تضاعف في
غضون اسبوع
بحسب المعلومات التي جمعتها فرقنا
الميدانيه فان اعداد النازحين داخليا في
السودان تضاعفت خلال الاسبوع الماضي وهناك
الان اكثر من 700 الف نازح داخليا بسبب
القتال الذي بدا في الخامس عشر من ابريل
المنسقيه العامه لمعسكرات النازحين
واللاجئين باقليم دارفور طالبت المجتمع
الدولي والامم المتحده بتقديم الخدمات
الاساسيه الطارئه للمتضررين جراء الحرب
وصفه الوضع الانساني بالكارثي واوضحت في
بيان لها ان مراكز ايواء النازحين بمدينه
الجنينه غرب دارفور تفتقر الى الخدمات
الاساسيه مثل مياه الشرب والماكل والادويه
والماء
من جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
في بيان لها عن تنفيذها لست رحلات اجلاء
منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان الى
المملكه كما اورد بيان وزاره الدفاع عن
بلوغ عدد من تم اجلائهم عبر طائرات القوات
الجويه الى السعوديه
نحو 530 شخصا بينهم سعوديون واخرون ينتمون
لثلاث وعشرين دوله فيما وصل عدد الرحلات
الاجنبيه القادمه من السودان الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده الى 26 رحله
على متنها اكثر من 2800 شخص من رعايا
الهند باكستان السودان اندونيسيا المغرب
وكوريا الجنوبيه
تستعد الى طائرات وطلائع الجسر الجوي
السعودي اللغاتي لمساعده الشعب السوداني
بالاقلاع عبر عديد من المساعدات التي سيتم
ارسالها عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
ستحمل بعشره اطنان موزعه على عدد من
المساعدات الهوائيه والغذائيه والدوائيه
وتحمل على متنها ايضا فريق من مركز الملك
سلمان بالاضافه الى فريق حمايه سيذهب
مباشره الى مطار بورتسودان لانزال هذه
المساعدات مباشره كما انه سيكون هنالك
طائره اخرى ستقلع بعد ساعات من مطار
الرياض الى بورت السودان لانزال المساعدات
مباشره الى المطار السوداني سنتحدث اكثر
مع الدكتور سامر الجطيلي متحدث الرسمي
باسم مركز الملك سلمان للغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور حدثنا عن اولى طلائع هذا
الجسر وما تحمله من مساعدات حياكم الله
تنطلق اول طائره يتم تحويلها تحميلها
حاليا وهي اول طائره من الجسر الجوي
انفاذا لتوجيهات سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين واوليعه عهده الامين
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه
للشعب السوداني الشقيق هذه الطائرات تحمل
حوالي عشر اطنان من المواد الغذائيه
والمواد الايوائيه وكذلك المواد الطبيه
والتي تمثل الحقيقه اهم الاحتياجات في هذه
المرحله سوف تتبع هذه الطائره طائره اخرى
اليوم وسوف يستمر هذا الجسر الجوي باذن
الله عز وجل حتى نصل الى مستهدفنا وحتى
نحقق توجيه سامي الكريم بايصال المساعدات
للاشقاء في السودان هذا اول الخير نسال
الله عز وجل التوفيق ونسال الله عز وجل ان
نكون على قدر هذه المهمه الكبيره التي
اوليت لنا في مركز الملك سلمان الشكر
الجزير لوزاره الدفاع لل الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه والتي الحقيقه تقوم الان مشكوره
بهذا الجسر الجوي نسعى باذن الله عز وجل
لتحقيق اثر وصناعه الحقير تغيير في حياه
المحتاجين في هذه المرحله من الازمه
والصراع في السودان شكرا جزيلا دكتور اذا
انت استعد هذه الطائره الى الاقلاع بعد
قليل وهي هذه الطائره ستحمل هذه
المساعده الواقعه بين بورتسودان الى
الخرطوم على ان تستمر هذه العمليه خلال
الايام القادمه وسط حمله شعبيه نودي لها
هنا بالسعوديه للتبرع على ان تستمر هذه
الى ايام واسابيع قادمه وان تصل الى كافه
الولايات السودانيه
التي تحتاج هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل عبد
المحسن الحربي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
الرياض
وقد ادت الحرب الى شل الحركه التجاريه في
السودان بسبب القتال حيث توقفت العديد من
الشاحنات في بورتسودان وهي محمله بالبضائع
وتعتبر هذه المدينه محورا اساسيا في
عمليات النقل التجاريه في السودان وقد
يؤدي توقف عمليات النقل التجاري الى ازمه
كبيره في البلاد
التي تشهد قتالا داخليا منذ اسابيع جينا
قبل الحواجز ده ولهنا لسه ما خشينا
ولقينا
الحين
يعني في الظروف هذه الحرب كلها متعطله لكن
نحن في قطاع النقل نعاني معانيه شديده
لانه عندنا سواقين اصبحوا قاعدين
دارين مصاريف عندهم اسر
نشاط الخمسه مستمره فيها ايضا
علماء من جامعه كاليفورنيا يحضرون من
تفاعل نهر جليدي في جرينلاند مع المد
والجزر ما سيتسبب بارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر
بشكل اسرع
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه انفجرت اعمال شغب واشتباكات في
كراتشي بباكستان بعد اعتقال الشرطه
الباكستانيه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان على ذمه التحقيق في قضيه فساد بعد حكم
من المحكمه العليا في اسلام اباد
والقضيه المتهم فيها خان بالكسب غير
المشروع هي واحده من اكثر من مئه قضيه
مرفوعه ضده منذ ان اطاح به تصويت
برلماني من السلطه في ابريل نيسان من
العام الماضي واثارت محاولات اعتقال عمران
خان في وقت سابق احتجاجات واشتباكات بين
الشرطه وانصاره لكنه ينفي كافه الاتهامات
ضده بالفساد ويعتبر القضايا مسيسه وواحيه
[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران
خان وفي مقطع مسجل قبل اعتقاله قال انه
مستعد للذهاب الى السجن بمحض ارادته مؤكدا
انه ليس مدانا باي قضيه تستدعي القاء
القبض عليه
اذا كان لدى شخص ما اوامر بالقاء القبض
عليه فاحضروا لي مذكره توقيف سيكون محامي
الخاص بانتظاري انا مستعد للذهاب الى
السجن بنفسي صنع مشهد مثير سيهدر الموارد
كما لو كان اكبر مجرم في البلاد قادما
قدموا اوامر مباشره لاعتقالي بالرغم من
عدم وجود اي قضيه ضدي الا انني مستعد
نفسيا للسجن
حزب حركه الانصاف الباكستانيه الذي يقوده
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان كان قد
طالب انصاره باغلاق البلاد ردا على اعتقال
زعيم الحزب من جهه اعلنت الشرطه
الباكستانيه حاله الاستعداد القصوى التي
شهدت اشتباكات بين انصار الحزب وقوات
الامن
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
اليه من اسلام اباد لا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك
الى اين تتجه الاوضاع في باكستان عموما
وفي كراتشي ولهور خصوصا وهل يستطيع انصار
خان قلب الطاوله على الجميع ام لا
نعم طالب لا تزال الاوضاع متوتره والاعصاب
مشدوده هنا في السماوات تحديدا وفي كافه
المناطق الباكستانيه
منذ اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
من امام او من محيط محكمه اسلام اباد
العليا خرج العشرات من انصاره في عدد من
المدن الباكستانيه هذه الاعداد الان تشهد
تزايدا او شهد التزايدا خلال الساعات
الماضيه لا سيما في لاهور وفيره والبندي
وفي كراتشي ايضا جرت هناك اشتباكات او
مواجهات بين قوات الامن الباكستانيه
والمتظاهرين تم خلالها اطلاق الائره
المسيله للدموع وقام بعض المتظاهرين
بمحاوله التوجه الى بعض
الاحياء الحساسه لنقل في عدد من المدن
حينها قررت السلطات نشر تعزيزات من الشرطه
وقوات الدرك
قوات مكافحه الشغب للتصدي لهؤلاء
المتظاهرين والحيلوله دون اقتحام عدد من
المقر السياديه
المهمه في كل من مدينه
تحديدا الوضع لا يزال متوتر والانظار تتجه
الان الى ربما القضاء الباكستاني محكمه
العليا كبير القضاه اليوم كان عبر عن
امتعاضه من اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان من محيط المحكمه لا تزال القضيه
قيد البحث ولا نعلم ان كان سيتم اصدار
القرار هذا اليوم او غدا بشان
ملابسات عمليه اعتقال رئيس ازور الوزراء
السابق عمران خان لاسيما وان
اعتقاله لم يكن مدرجا ضمن جدول
محكمه استعمالات العليا وانما جاء بناء
كما قال وزير الداخليه الباكستانيه
ثناء الله بناء على مذكره توقيف صادره في
الاول من هذا الشهر من خلال مكتب المحاسبه
الوطنيه وهو الجهاز الحكومي الذي يعنى
بمكافحه قضايا الفساد هناك اتهامات لعمران
خان بانه نعم بس عبد الرحمن هل ينظر
الشارع او جزء كبير من الشارع الباكستاني
على ان ما يجري مع عمران خان هو اولا
واخيرا مساله تصفيه حسابات سياسيه معه
وان يعني فتح ملف غسيل الاموال الان بهذه
الطريقه يعني يشوبه الكثير من الاسئله او
كثير من علامات الاستفهام
الشارع الباكستاني حقيقه منقسم بين مؤيد
للاحزاب المشاركه في الائتلاف الحاكم وبلا
شك رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان لديه حضور جماهير والشعب كبير لاسيما
في ظل الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه التي تمر
بها باكستان قضيه
القضايا الفساد هذا هذا الملف سبق العمران
خان ما في حكومه عمران خان ان تم اعتقال
ربما معظم قاده الاحزاب الباكستانيه
وايداعهم في السجن والسؤال الذي يطرحه
المراقبون ان كان قاده الاحزاب السابقين
قد امضوا
امضوا اياما واسابيع بل ربما اشهر في تحت
التحقيق وتحت الحبس الاحتياطي فلماذا لا
يتم ذلك مع عمران خان هناك انتقادات من
قبل الائتلاف الحاكم بان هناك معامله
تفضيليه يحظى بها عمران خان كان هناك
العديد من مذكرات التوقيف بحقه ومذكرات
على اعتقال بالحق لكنه في كل مره كان يفلت
من الاعتقال ويحصل على كفالات مؤقته تحول
دون اعتقاله لكن نعم ساكتفي بهذا القدر
لضيق الوقت من اسلام مباد مراسل العربيه
عبد الرحمن المزيني شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
الرحمن على كل هذه المتابعه
الان الى موضوع الانتخابات في تركيا حيث
يشكل الناخبون الاكراد نسبه لا باس بها من
عدد الناخبين ولهم دور مهم في هذه
الانتخابات ويمثلهم عدد من الاحزاب ابرزهم
وادبرهم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي المعارض
لاردوغان والذي استقطب بدوره حزب الدعوه
الحره هذه بار وهو حزب محافظ صغير يدعمه
الاكراد المحافظون
[موسيقى]
رغم عملهما معا في مكتب بسيط للعقارات بحي
اسانيورت في اسطنبول الا ان ايدن ونوري
ليس على قلب رجل واحد فيما يخص الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه
كلاهما من اكراد تركيا لكن توجهاتهم
السياسيه التي كانت متوافقه فيما مضى
اختلفت في هذه الانتخابات
في سنوات حكمه الاولى كان الحزب الحاكم
جيدا على كافه الاصعده كثير من الاكراد
كانوا يصوتون لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه
لكن في الاونه الاخيره ولا سيما بعد
التدهور الاقتصادي اصبحت مقتنعا بضروره
التغيير لذلك لن اصوت لحزب العداله
والتنميه بل لكمال كالجدار اوغلو بان
ساصوت للرئيس اردوغان انا راضا عن سياساته
تجاه الاكراد واحبه شخصيا لذلك سامنحه
صوتي من جديد
تقدر نسبه الاكراد في تركيا بخمسه عشر في
المئه من عدد السكان واعتاد حزب العداله
والتنميه ان يكون الحزب الثاني كسبا
للاصوات في المناطق ذات الغالبيه الكرديه
خلف حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الذي
يملك القاعده الانتخابيه الاكبر في اوساط
الاكراد لكن طليق الذي مارسته الحكومه ضد
الحزب الكردي وسعيها لاغلاقه دفع الكثير
من الاكراد الى اعاده النظر بموقفهم
السياسي من الحزب الحاكم في البلاد
تحسبا من قرار الاغلاق قرر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي خوض الانتخابات باسم حزب
اليسار الاخضر واسست تحالفا للاحزاب
اليساريه وهو تحالف العمل والحريه
التحالف الجديد قرر عدم اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بل قرر دعم مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوكلو ضد اردوغان
كما ذكرتم يبلغ عدد الاكراد في تركيا ما
بين 12 الى 15 مليون مواطن الحزب الذي
يعتبر ذاته ممثلا للاكراد في تركيا حصل في
الانتخابات الاخيره على خمسه ملايين صوت
وهذا يعني ان ليس جميع الناخبين الاكراد
يصوتون وفق معيار الهويه العرقيه بل هناك
هويه الدين وكذلك دوافع اقتصاديه وغيرها
من المعايير التي تحدد توجه الناخب التركي
في عمليه التصويت في مقابل دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لمرشح المعارضه استطاع تحالف
الشعب وهو الائتلاف الحاكم جذب حزب الدعوه
الحره والمعروف باسم حزب هدى بار الى
تحالفه ويستقطب هدى بار المحافظين الاكراد
ويعتبر من الاحزاب الاسلاميه المتشدده
لكنه لا يحظى بشعبيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي رغم ان مرشح المعارضه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو انتزع دعما من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكن كتله القوميين في معسكر
المعارضه ترفض هذا الدعم لانها تراه حزبا
مؤيدا لحزب العمال الكردستاني في المقابل
نال انضمام حزب هدى بار لتحالف الشعب
استياء بسبب تهم تلاحق الحزب بارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه هي معادله معقده تعكس
اختلاط المصالح والتحالفات في انتخابات
ليست كسابقاتها زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
اكد علماء الجليد من جامعه كاليفورنيا
ومختبر الدفع النفاث التابع لناسا اكدوا
ان نهرا جليديا كبيرا في شمال غرب جرينلان
يتفاعل مع المد والجزر في المحيط ما تسبب
بذوبان لم يكن معروفا من قبل وارتفاع
مستوى سطح البحر بشكل اسرع
وكشفت الملاحظات ان خط تماس النهر الجليدي
وهو المنطقه التي تبدا فيها الصفيحه
الجليديه في الاتصال بالمحيط يمكن ان
يتغير بشكل كبير مع دخول المد والجزر كل
يوم
بين عامي 2016 و2022 ادابت دورات المد
والجزر الاكثر دفئا تله يبلغ ارتفاعها 670
قدما في الجانب السفلي من هذا النهر
الجليدي هذه الظاهره يمكن ان تتفاقم في
السنوات المقبله مع ارتفاع درجات حراره
المحيطات شبكه سي ان ان ذكرت مؤخرا ان
درجات حراره سطح البحر كانت في اعلى
مستوياتها المسجله هذا الربيع ما اثار قلق
العلماء من انه قد يكون جزءا من اتجاه
جديد يتسم بالخطوره فيما تثير دراسات
علميه مزيدا من المخاوف بشان الاحتمال
المقلق لارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر الذي يهدد
السواحل في جميع انحاء العالم
شكرا لك زياده اعزائي المشاهدين نشاط
الخامسه من العربيه انتهت رتبت التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات